une passerelle un ponton un Marett et un
nid d'observation supérieur à 3 m de
hauteur prendront place dans cette marre
au canard à Chevreuse un projet
entrepris depuis août 2023 par la
municipalité sur ce point d'eau de 3000
m² ce projet est critiqué depuis sa mise
en place par l'association Chevreuse
environnement et patrimoine selon eux
l'écosystème a été détruit l'association
craint une forte augmentation du nombre
de visiteurs car le site est au pied de
la vallée de Chevreuse Chevreuse
environnement et patrimoine est une
petite association très récente à
Chevreuse et a eu l'idée de lancer cette
pétition en ligne pour dire son
opposition au projet d'aménagement de la
Mar au canard dont le chantier a été
lancé récemment on se trouve face à un
écosystème qui est extrêmement perturbé
et qui sans doute se reconstituera
puisque la nature est résiliante mais
était-il nécessaire de créer tous ces
tourments à la nature pour un projet
d'aménagement dont la pertinence
échappe la pétition a recueilli 10000
signatures mais pour la mère de
Chevreuse ce chiffre est à sous-évaluer
dans ces 10000
personnes je sais pas si vous avez
regardé de près il y a du Guatemala du
Canada l'Afrique du Sud enfin des gens
signent de partout donc ça déjà je suis
très heureuse de voir que les enjeux
environnementaux intéressent bien
au-delà de nos frontières l'ambition
c'était de remettre en valeur cet espace
de manière à ce que tout le monde puisse
trouver son compte avec un volet
environnemental un volet biodiversité et
également un volet pédagogique les
travaux sont estimés à plus d'un million
d'euros les subventions s'éléveront à
€.